[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the president will
address the nation a little less than an
hour from now he'll make his case for a
protective wall along our southern
border
then he'll broadly argue that America's
immigration problems are real they're
not a figment of our imagination they're
hurting the country badly
the president will say all that in a few
minutes but he will not go unchallenged
of course the Democratic Party and it's
unpaid operatives in the news media will
make their case too in fact they're not
waiting for 9:00 p.m. to do that they're
up early every day reading from the same
set of talking points
today's slogan is simple don't believe
your own eyes none of this is real
everything is just fine it is absolute
fiction that there's a national
emergency here
showing that this is not about a crisis
it's a political ploy crisis crisis and
it's a crisis that doesn't exist they
are trying to create the notion that
there's an emergency and something
should be done immediately to prevent it
there is no emergency on the southern
border being from New Jersey no national
emergencies you know we've seen
superstorm sandy we've seen 911 this is
not a national emergency and certainly
this marriage emergency is completely
made up a wall is a colossal waste of
money for a crisis that doesn't exist
but even if he declares a national
emergency he's lying even if he declares
it it will be a declaration of a
falsehood this whole idea of declaring a
national emergency is ludicrous because
there isn't one
so repeat after me no national emergency
the crisis at the border is fake it's
fraudulent it's totally made-up think
leprechauns or low-cal ice cream
something only kids and dumb people
believe in actually know what the border
crisis is like it's like that imaginary
caravan from Honduras a few months ago
the one that marched all the way to
Tijuana with TV cameras in tow
but didn't really exist they're telling
you the existential threat to America
there's a bunch of poor refugees a
thousand miles away this group of folks
we don't even know where they are
they're way down there they've been
running on an imaginary Caravan this
stupid Caravan
you know it's a lie that this Caravan is
is a problem of that magnitude
programming on the caravan was
propaganda yep caravans fake to breathe
easy America a lot of the problems
you've been worried about don't need
solutions because they're not real
that's what the media are telling us
about illegal immigration and a lot of
other things and it's a relief but it
does leave at least one big question
unanswered if none of this is really
happening
why does so many people think that it is
how are millions of Americans
experiencing the same hallucination at
the same time and the answer of course
is it's an illusion Americans are being
tricked tricked by that dastardly Fox
News and those demagogues in primetime
who won't shut up despite being warned
repeatedly by the authorities to be
quiet if you know what's good for you
shadowy saboteurs of course played a
role as well they always do the New York
Times ran a piece the other day
explaining that Donald Trump only
supports a border wall because Roger
stone told him to was part of a
political ploy stone meanwhile now
appears to be caught up in the Russia
investigation and that makes some sense
if you think about it Donald Trump's
election and a wall on the Mexican
border nobody in Washington could
imagine wanting either one of those
things or for that matter imagining
anyone else in America wanting them so
there has to be a secret cabal pushing
this crap Vladimir Putin Roger stone Fox
News they're all in it together somehow
maybe Robert Muller will get to the
bottom of it that's honestly how people
in Washington think trust us we live
here of course it's completely
delusional demented actually but once
you understand where these people are
coming from it's hard to blame them for
constructing these fantasies the next
time you see some angry face and CNN's
shouting about this or that remember
this person isn't arguing for change
this person is arguing for more of this
arguing for a permanent extension of the
way things are they may claim they're
mad about Trump or the wall or whatever
name the topic but those are just
symptoms of the larger problem the thing
they fear most and that is an assault on
the status quo they like the status quo
they're deeply vested in the status quo
this is the group that's become richer
and happier since the financial crisis
of 2008 there aren't a lot of those
people in America most of them live in a
handful of big cities a lot of them seem
to have cable television contracts
somehow and what this group fears most
is that some idiot will come along ask a
bunch of uncomfortable questions and
wreck what has turned out to be a very
good deal for them low work high-paying
jobs cheap household help leafy stable
neighborhoods that look like it's 1965
in a corrupt and insular system of
higher education
that's essentially closed to outsiders
but that can be relied upon to keep this
whole scam going in perpetuity what
you're really looking at here is a
self-satisfied aristocracy all of those
are the same what they fear most is a
challenge to the way things are
keep that in mind tonight as you watch
their response we don't need walls
they'll tell you and they're right they
don't they already have their own